combien qui sont dans la rue en ce
moment manifestent contre un projet de
loi d'extradition mais le mécontentement
ne date pas d'hier
alors si vous le voulez bien on fait
pause et on recule alors au 19e siècle
la grande bretagne après la guerre
s'empare d'un petit groupe d'îles au sud
de la chine
c'est encore un territoire qui devait
prendre le chemin de la démocratie
libérale si vous voulez mais ça ne
devait pas durer parce que selon
l'accord entre les deux pays
hong kong devait demeurer territoire
britannique pendant 99 ans soit jusqu'en
1990 est donc cette année là encore
abandonne le drapeau britannique qui
intègre la république populaire de chine
la grande-bretagne
donc cette ce territoire mais à une
condition que c'est que hong kong garde
son autonomie donc son système
économique système politique également
ça fait l'objet d'un accord ça aussi une
période de transition qui doit durer 50
ans soit jusqu'en 2047
les réformateurs de l'époque accepte ce
compromis et lui donne il lui donne même
un nom ça s'appelle un pays deux
systèmes
mais depuis ce temps là sébastien pékin
a un peu changé d'idée exactement
ben parce que il faut dire que lille
hong kong a perdu de son pouvoir
économique à l'époque de l'accord
son économie représentait 20% de toute
l'économie chinoise alors qu'en 2017
c'était plutôt 3% donc perdre de pouvoir
il faut dire également que les
réformateurs de l'époque ont fait place
à des figures bien plus conservatrices
notamment le président xi jingping qui à
certains égards veut faire taire les
voix opposées au pouvoir chinois un
exemple de ces voix dissidentes ce sont
ces énormes veillée qui se tiennent
chaque année à hong kong à la chandelle
en mémoire du mouvement pro démocratie
de tiananmen alors qu'elles sont vous
savez interdites ailleurs en chine alors
pékin selon les opposants veut
s'immiscer dans les affaires d'hong kong
le dernier exemple c'est ce projet de
loi qui permettrait à pékin de traduire
les criminels chez elle en chine les
criminels mais aussi peut-être bien les
dissidents politiques
alors il ya une solution pour les
hongkongais et c'est la rue sébastien et
merci